he is super bowl-winning quarterback
Russell Wilson how are you rustling the
show my friend how you doing I am better
for talking to you thanks for calling
back in I appreciate it what was it like
to be part of a game like that where
you're firing back at a young
quarterback who's firing back at you
like that well it was definitely a
battle back and forth it was a the fun
thing to be a part of and the key thing
there was we got a huge huge win so
there was a it was pretty big well I
mean so when you're on the sideline were
you aware I know because sometimes you
you were probably just looking at the
tablet chatting with your coaches and
then suddenly you have to run back on
the field well or were you watching
deshaun Watson at any point during that
game Russell well no I really kind of
just focus on getting ready to go back
out there every series you know and I'm
really sitting down with Coach pebble
sitting down with Austin Davis and and
communicating about what our playing is
and how we're gonna go attack them and
so that's what I'm doing you know and in
those moments but it was it was cool to
peek up at the screen and uh you know
not you know just to see the level that
you know the Shawn was playing it was
pretty cool as a rookie it's pretty
impressive well you would also know
firsthand what it's like to play
impressively as a rookie and start
balling out before people expect that
well what what did you see again in your
opponent when you had a chance that may
have reminded you of yourself in your
rookie season Russell well why I think
he's a true competitor you know I think
that he's played in big moments big
games you know you know he's been the
national championship he's he doesn't
he's done things and he's calling me you
know he's uh nothing nothing that kind
of gets in the way of where he's trying
to go so you know I think they've got a
great quarterback for a long time there
and I think he'll be I think he'll be a
star for a long time and you know he
works hard so I love watching the guy
but the last question for you on him did
you chat with him after the game at all
yeah yeah we actually talked before
beforehand and then after it
and after two as well and you know
Deshawn is a guy you know actually funny
thing is my old trainer it used to train
the Sean to so we kind of we've kind of
been in the same world before so we're
gonna probably get together this
offseason and work together we talked
about it just you know you know just I
can you know be around him and vice
versa and we can continue to push each
other
Seahawks quarterback Russell Wilson
joining us here on the Rich Eisen show
and your your team got you new left
tackle Russell I mean what do you think
of the acquisition of Dwayne brown who
you saw protect DeSean just a couple of
days ago well it's crazy how fast it all
happened to me you think about it he was
just here in Seattle playing and playing
against us he should have just he should
just showered and stayed here and kept
his things here but you had to go always
back to Houston but you know I think I
think obviously brain Browns a propyl
attack all prototype of tackle he's a
really really special player you know
he's a grown man you know he's done it
for nine ten years or whatever so he's
definitely going to continue to bring
even more leadership to our team and and
which is exciting to see you know you
think of do you think about that I think
that he's a tough minded person he's
from Virginia so you know he's he's
right down the street for me actually he
grew it he grew up went to Hermitage
high which is in Richmond Virginia so
he's a VA boy I know I know he's gonna
know he's gonna bring his a-game but uh
you think about all the guys that we've
had the guys that of you know an
offensive line this year they've been
battling battling battling it's been
really cool just to watch those guys you
know really step up to the plate and
allow us to win you know these came so
far and they had Dwane Brown to a mix
hit me great so has this offense it's
just again to me just watching from my
couch or from sitting there at the NFL
Network it looks like the offense is
clicking better in the last four weeks
than it did the first four what has it
seemed to you to be Russell
well I think you know you know rich we
always want to be on a constant
progression man we always want to keep
growing and keep building and there's
you know we've played some tough teams
we've come up some huge huge wins we've
done some really cool special things but
I think for us it's all about you know
steady wins the race man and it's
staying the course you know and then I
just continue to building and keep
working and that that's where that's
where great things happen it's all in
the work and there's no secret sauce
it's just the work and I think that's
where guides are really as a team
offense defense special teams everybody
that's where we're really buying into it
and things are happening a good way
couple more minutes here with Russell
Wilson you know I've known you since you
you were drafted obviously out of
Wisconsin and you were kind enough to be
on my first televised podcast show that
this show that I'm on right now well I
mean you you were it was obvious what
was going on in Seattle with you
certainly when we were told that we only
had a few minute window with you because
you were gonna be in the film room the
entire time and that's something you
don't hear about from a rookie but that
said I mean how his father a changed you
Russell how has that changed you now
that you're in a different part of life
here that's a great question man it's a
beautiful question I think that um you
know when you have kids and you know I'm
a steps first of all the step father so
to be able to to be able to love a child
you know biologically not yours and just
to love that kid you know there's you
know there's no greater love and that
you know just understanding that you
know and just embracing and loving
loving your baby's future is you know as
as if he was my own you know what I mean
and and there's such a special special
thing in relationship that we have and I
mean in terms of having baby Sienna you
know just it's the greatest miracle of
all you know watching watching the baby
you know form and in watching a baby you
know coming out and then and then
ultimately you know seeing house seeing
us now six months it's just God is a
good God and I think I think I'm every
day for that just you know every day I
come home you know how good the day is
matter how not-so-good or whatever is
going on you see come home and you see
these kids and they they smile from ear
to ear they run up to you and it's just
it's a really really uh it's a humbling
thing and it's an amazing thing and
that's what life's really worth living
for you know and and all these things
it's you know at the end of the day the
effect and the love and and the care
that you can give your children is the
most important thing because they're
going to be the ones to affect the next
generation and and that's my prayer for
our world is that you know fathers and
mothers can can love their kids and show
them the way is that part of the reason
why you're speaking out on socially
active things and issues more than
perhaps before Russell Wow you missed a
time and place for everything I think
sometimes I don't think no I don't have
necessarily why I think that you know
it's been it's been an interesting time
right now and just you know the only way
that we can fix the was to love the
world a couple of one last question for
you Russell Wisconsin sitting there at
for overall nobody's talking about him
everybody's talking about Penn State
Ohio State my alma mater Michigan which
we're gonna face each other in a while
why do you think that is you know I
think that uh people get bored with
consistency you know can't get bored
consistency baby you know I'm sayin rich
you just got a fetus K State of course
man and what's constants been cool to
watch well over the years I think Paul
Chris first of all is doing a phenomenal
phenomenal job there he was he was great
when I was there as an offensive
coordinator and amazing coach and just
amazing person and great leader really
coach this guy's really loved the game
and you know I think Wisconsin's doing
that just now you know they're their
players seem to really be in love with a
game and I'm sure that starts with coach
Chris and last one for you what do you
think of Jose Altuve Russell you being
an infielder somebody who's been talked
about in his career about overcoming
shall we say vertical challenges in life
what do you
Jose Altuve is gonna be one of the
greatest players of all time hands down
I mean he is a true true superstar he's
doing things that are unbelievable to
watch you know the way he's hitting the
ball the way he brings passion to the
game he al he elevates his teammates you
know so it's fun watching this world I
mean can it get any better I mean
watching watching the Dodgers versus
versus the Houston you know Astros it's
pretty it's pretty amazing and then then
you think about it to look at Justin
Verlander is gonna be on the mound you
know he's actually a good friend of mine
I grew up with them down the street and
my brother played with him too as well
and you know it's just just watching
Justin you know ever since he was 10
years old 14 years old 18 years old all
the way through college and everything
else and I'm good gross mean I grew up
15 minutes down the street and the thing
about you know he's got a chance to win
in World Series where where he deserves
to be and I know on the best pitchers in
baseball and one of the best pitchers of
all time you know it's gonna be cool to
see it you know I it's gonna be a great
game well I mean your game against
Houston in a way was similar to the
Houston Dodgers game five that played
out where just went back and forth and
whoever had the had the last at-bat was
gonna win so congratulations to that
Brussels on that win and we always I
always appreciate chatting with you you
got it there's Russell Wilson for more
Rich Eisen show tune - audience Channel
239 on DirecTV or download the
doesn't show up